Ami's with us in Sacramento
hi Amy how are you I'm good how are you
better than I deserve what's up I'm
calling my husband and I are in baby
step 3b and we're so thankful for
everything that you do but my
sister-in-law is in quite the financial
mess and she has a really good
opportunity right now to clean it all up
because she is not paying rent we've
talked to her about you we you know she
says she's read your book but you know
she just continues to to spend unwisely
and just get in deeper trouble so I
wanted to see if you had any suggestions
for encouraging somebody to try to get
that free and really start working at it
it's really hard to watch people you
love be stupid yes when I bring in pain
to themselves and when you want them to
fix their life more than they want to
fix their life easy that's hard it's
hard to watch I've got a friend whose
kids doing heroin right now and you
can't make it I mean you can't make
people want to do stuff you know and we
want grown kid I mean little kid but I
mean it's just Kylie it's just hard um
I don't know how to make somebody want
something other than to talk to them
there's a couple of reasons that people
might do things like that okay they've
got to end it like that meaning they've
got the information to fix their life in
front of them why do they not engage in
it well reason number one could simply
be just complete immaturity and lack of
character reason number two could be
hopelessness they see the information
but they don't believe it'll work for
them hmm and so how much detail have you
all sat and gone into her stuff with her
and shown her where she to work that
snowball with her income and with no
rent right now what she could do um my
husband sat down with her
oh maybe it was a year ago at this point
and could a budget with her I'm so sorry
and just didn't see a lot of progress on
it and he showed her her her car was
impounded at the time and he showed her
how she could get that paid and and I
think she saw some hope there but then
you see she never how old was she hon
she's 35 how has she existed to this
point being this stupid enabling by a
mother yeah parents they'd she's filed
bankruptcy once her parents at one point
you know took control of her finances
and cleaned everything up and then when
she got into control again
you know she ended up and now dad is
gone and mom has Alzheimer's she's
caring for mom and that's why you know
she has your community you can't you you
hope you want this more than she wants
it you can't help her yeah
you can't help her the only thing you
can do is just continually put in front
of her but you're doing it you need to
lower your hope level for her until she
until you see something from her because
you're going to step in and be the next
set of enablers if you're not careful
this girl's gone from enabler to enabler
to enabler throughout her life and she's
getting ready at the ball and just let
her know when you're stupid catches up
with you because you won't deal with it
lien will show you how hard work to get
out but we will not bail you out and
we're not going to bail you out now if
you want to work on it right now we'll
work on right now I'll show you how to
do it I'll be your biggest cheerleader
I'll be your coach I'll be your
accountability partner we'll pay for you
to go through Financial Peace University
we are not paying any of your bills
you're 35 freakin years old you are a
grown woman put on your big-girl panties
and let's go to work that's what you got
to do now and this is this is real life
here and so you just need to sit down
whether it's probably you not you
because you'll be the evil sister-in-law
it gets called names and everything else
let your let her brother do it just
and lovingly put his arm around and say
sis you're a knucklehead when you quit
being a knucklehead I love you and I'll
work with you away from knucklehead land
but right now you are living in the land
of knuckleheads because you are one you
may be the queen of the knuckleheads but
I love you you're my knucklehead and you
just be sit over there and just be
stupid until you get tired of it and
when you get tired of it
I'll show you how to walk out and I've
got I've got a friend that I had to have
that same conversation with it's
alcoholic and he keeps drinking himself
in out of every marriage and out of
every job and then to homelessness and
in and out and I can't fix it for him I
want I want more he wants it for him I
saw the guys got unbelievable potential
but he can't keep his freakin lips off
the bottle you know and hadn't hadn't
decided to yet and yet just have to
reach a point the 12-steppers call it
hit and bottom right when you hit that
bottom and you know you have that
turning point where you go okay enough
of you know enough of living in manure
up to my neck I'm going to change then
you change but it's just that there's
this weird thing about human nature and
and you are obviously a kind person and
an intelligent person and you really
want her to behave and to be responsible
because you can see the potential that
she has more than she sees it and you
can just you know pray for and and you
know be encouraging but we're not going
to you know condone knuckle head
movements we're not going to go you know
that was a really good idea to go lease
a car you idiot you know I'm not going
to tell you that's a good idea it's not
all people I love
and so it's a really good idea for you
to spend everything you make when you
got no rent dummy you know come on
doofus really and you just you can have
whatever conversation you want to have
in your family or whatever vernacular
you would use and how but but again I
think it's probably her brother puts his
arm around her and says look says when
you decide you don't be a knucklehead
we're hitting we're ready to help you
but we're not going to do this for you
and you call us when you're ready and
when you hit bottom and you're scared
enough to do something
about this we can show you how to get
out cuz I think you can't show her how
to get out the good news is it's not
rocket science
thanks for the call hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]